así es muy buenas tardes raúl pues lo
cierto es que fue una reunión en la que
no sólo estaban los ministros sino
también los secretarios de estado así
que había cerca de unas 40 personas
reunidas alrededor de manuel marco aquí
en el palacio del elíseo esta mañana una
reunión que además se realizó en salón
en el salón de fiestas de este de este
edificio allí se tomaron puesto su
tiempo finalmente para discutir segundos
dijo el portavoz del gobierno sobre lo
logrado a lo largo de estos cinco años
pero también sobre lo que ha venido
haciéndose esta semana en cuanto al
poder adquisitivo con el alza que
todavía continúa en los precios de los
hidrocarburos medidas también pues para
que el poder adquisitivo de los
franceses no se vea demasiado afectado y
que también fue es francés reitera su
posición en buscar un cese al fuego en
ucrania por supuesto se le preguntó
varias veces a gabriela tal quien es el
portavoz del gobierno si éste era o no
el último consejo de ministros de en
todo caso el gobierno de roncas textron
castells que llegó también muy sonriente
a esta reunión y él dijo que no podía
decir ni sí ni no que en realidad pues
ese primer mandato de manuel ma comba
hasta el próximo 13 de mayo así que
todavía le quedan algunos días sin
embargo pues fue el ministro de economía
bueno quien nos da a entender que si fue
el último porque en su cuenta de
instagram puso una foto de su puesto el
puesto que siempre ocupa en este consejo
de ministros- con un mensaje diciendo
que era un momento de muchísima emoción
porque este era el último consejo de
ministros en todo caso de este gobierno
castex